il faut savoir que dès qu'il est arrivé
il s'est fait défoncer par les
supporters vous allez voir c'était un
vrai feuilleton
ce qui s'est passé pour neymar samedi
regardez samedi au parc des princes le
psg affronter strasbourg
un match sans grand enjeu sauf pour les
supporters parisiens qui attendaient
avec impatience l'événement majeur de la
journée
le retour de neymar après 126 jours
d'absence sous le maillot parisien
revoilà neymar un retour attendu de
façon très mitigée après les différentes
polémiques de ces derniers mois une
déclaration qui n'est pas du tout passé
pour les fans du psg hier le numéro 10
était donc attendu de pied ferme par des
supporters remontés à bloc et ça n'a pas
manqué dès les premières secondes de jeu
le joueur a compris que le match allait
être compliqué à chaque fois que le
champion toucher la balle une partie du
stade le siffler copieusement
ce à quoi ne s'attendait peut-être pas
les supporters les plus remontés c'est
que neymar allait sauver le match en
marquant le seul et unique but de la
rencontre à la toute dernière minute
sont à l'image de son côté neymar a
réagi au comportement des supporters et
à l'échec et si lors des prochains
matches du psg neymar produit son
exploit les polémiques du passé
pourraient peut-être être oubliés s'est
fait sifflé toute la partie on sait ni
psg m'a perd 0 0 contre strasbourg et la
éclair de génie
mine de rien est ce que vous pensez que
l année mares composés qui va être au
sifflet prochain match dans michel
beaucoup je pense que la fin du match
tout on était de gauche vous étiez vous
aviez fit six films cinéma en tant que
supporters du chinois de chez moi je les
sifflets baj s'il continue à marquer
vous avez fait votre choix parmi les
lamas temps fermer nos gueules salle
jenny seront là on n'a pas la chance
d'avoir des six gros joueur qui joue au
psg il joue battant ça il faut oublier
fois avant ses nerfs il fallait deux
buts exceptionnels qui l'a marqué
ç'aurait pu clore la ferme et la
déclaration d'après et xavier regarder
marc il arrive dans tout le temps à
l'extérieur je trouve ça très mal a tenu
des propos assez fort mais c est quand
même un peu de coeur pendant là dans la
gueule pendant une heure c'est normal je
sais bon après je pense que les
supporters vont se calmer
[Musique]
marina festaïres élevées et qu'il y ait
dans les rues de là s'est propagé et a
lancé qui partira pour aller c'est une
préférée casas bahia dit que jouer tous
les matches à l'extérieur voilà on fait
juste d'un fascinant c'était presque
parfait